des personnes qui créent un faux compte
avec un nom similaire où on voit là en
faisant en se faisant passer pour moi
c'est de l'escroquerie
j'espère qu'un pas trop de monde se font
avoir régulièrement on fait les
signalements bien sûr aux réseaux
sociaux
la police aussi mais c'est souvent des
personnes qui viennent de l'étranger et
qui ont flairé le bon coup
je ne suis pas la seule personnalité à
être qu'on me dira l ciblés par ce genre
de choix c'est le cas aussi de prêtres
qui n'ont même pas qu'ils sont même pas
ou qui ne sont plus sur les réseaux
sociaux
il ya des comptes à leurs noms qui
fleurissent alors
on a dû faire un communiqué des gens aux
personnes moi je ne communique jamais
indirects a pas de dialogue pas mais je
ne convertis ou jamais il ya des
demandes d'argent jamais il ya des
réponses à des messages privés etc ou
des demandes de brière et ses rails a
pas de réponse c'est pas le circuit
normal de communication la communication
est assez simple on peut me retrouver à
la cathédrale tous les dimanches soirs
après les veys brou aka catéchèse
d'emmaüs
voilà le mercredi pendant l'année sinon
mon programme et sur le site internet
tout le monde sait où je vais ce que je
fais et a pas de problème si quelqu'un
veut me voir il suffit d'aller là où je
suis ou peut-être que les gens ont fait
des dons puis bah ils ne le disent pas
où ils se disent tiens mon seigneur m'a
même pas remercié j'en sais rien il y
avait quelque chose de très intelligent
qui avait été fait afin de traiter
revers aussi qui avait été fait à
quelques quelques mois il avait alors là
c'est à mon avis ça c'est d'être gens
plus intelligents et que les autres
s'étaient renseignés un peu dans tous
les sens que tu rouge était passé dans
les dix dernières années et même quand
je sais pas évêques dont qu'il avait
envoyé des messages on en tient je
viendrai bientôt vous visitez dans un
mois ou deux et donc les recteurs des
évêques des supérieurs de religieux de
religieuses et communauté de laïcs ont
reçu des messages faisant à tu viens
bientôt alors j'ai dit non mais pas du
tout pour que ce me dit là donc un
premier un deuxième j'ai découvert qu'en
fait il y avait tout un réseau il avait
connecter tous m'ont tout mon ancien
réseau parce que là aussi mon programme
et en public
c'est assez simple de le d'essayer de
pirater voilà mais c'est pas un piratage
de compte encore une fois c'est une
escroquerie et un faux compte donc pour
repérer il suffit de voir que si la
personne vous réponds c'est que c'est
pas moi